[Musique]
sur compagnie de laurent brunner
directeur de versailles spectacles et on
va parler de la programmation assez
exceptionnel puisque son commencé des
250 ans de 2 sera de versailles alors on
va commencer puisqu'on à 250 kg à
quelqu'un d'autre qui a deux cent
cinquante ans qu'il est en même temps
que leurs adversaires
c'est beterz à oui alors c'est une
double révolution celle bien sûr d'avoir
construit ce théâtre et qu'il soit
toujours là parce que justement nous
avons brûlé et celle de beethoven qui
est sans doute le compositeur qu'on
imaginait on imaginerait le moins dans
les ors de versailles les est plutôt la
révolution best-of voilà et en même
temps il est l'enfant tout à fait de
cette époque là est autant on a pu
proposer à mozart par exemple d'obtenir
l'orgue de la chapelle royale
ce qu'il a refusé autant beethoven est
exactement le bon contemporain du
paysage puisqu'il arrive on va dire sur
le sur le tableau musical dans les
années 1790 et les kits en 1827 et
finalement il est vraiment le
contemporain non pas de la construction
de la salle mais de ses premières années
et donc il a joué essentiellement dans
des théâtres qui avait plus ou moins
cette époque cette époque là alors c'est
surtout l'occasion pour nous de dire au
public
venez écouter beethoven pour ceux qui
savent pas profitez-en c'est vraiment le
compositeur l'avant-garde c'est lui qui
a un vent de ça sauf que maintenant la
250 ans donc elle nous est passé dans
l'est dans le sens c'est vrai que c'est
un musicien révolutionnaire à tous les
sens du terme c'est que les musiciens de
la révolution et c'est une révolution
dans la musique aussi
voilà révolutionnaire parce que ça va
être le premier à vivre de sa musique
vraiment de ses investissements et pas
seulement de dépendances on va dire de
billetterie c'est aussi quelqu'un qui
est très influencé par les idées des
lumières et les idées de la révolution
française et jusqu'à jusqu'à jusqu'à
napoléon en tous cas on peut penser que
d'abord nous a trahis c'est idéal
et puis surtout musicalement il fait une
vraie révolution il fait une rupture
avec tout ce qui a été ancien le baroque
et soudain on a une oeuvre qui parle de
l'intérieur de chacun d'entre nous alors
c'est vraiment assez fantastique et là
par exemple on propose l'intégrale des
symphonies on doit écouter les neuf
symphonies en quatre ans
soit c'est une espèce de météorites
musicale fantastique on l'entend
vraiment un condensé de génie
littéralement
je rappelle que la cinquième et la
sixième et le concerto l'empereur ont
été créés le même soir par exemple on se
dit on aurait aimé être dans la salle
face à entendre pour la première fois
des oeuvres aussi extraordinaire c'est
fantastique
ou bien barré douglas qui viendra par
exemple faire tous les cinq concertos
pour piano et orchestre c'est pareil
c'est en deux soirs on a soudain on va
dire vraiment une flopée de
chefs-d'oeuvre et puis les entendre à la
suite ça les met tous en perspective on
l'entend le temps qui passe alors que
lui était sourd bien dans les bateaux
c'est vraiment excellent pauvres voilà
parce que c'était comme le drame de sa
vie et on finira avec les dix sonates
pour violon et piano que renaud capuçon
que la crise adorerais viendra jouer en
trois concerts le salon de ici mais
entre les deux entre les deux on va en
jouer à la chapelle en les quatre
premières les quatre suivantes à la
chapelle et les deux dernières ici où je
sais plus trop de détails mais une
espèce de voyage musical dans tout ce b
tort enfin oui inventeur à toi tout cas
je resterai pour piano melbourne les
neuf symphonies c'est quand même
incroyable sa wii et sur instruments
anciens parce que je crois que c'est
bien à versailles si on le peut pas
toujours mais de faire un respect de
l'instrument historique et beethoven sur
des instruments du xviiie dans la fin du
xviiie siècle du début du 19e
ça sonne c'est gardiner qui dit ça il
dit ça sommes comme la musique de la
révolution française et ça compte c'est
cette époque là alors 250 autres
méthodes autre anniversaire c'est des
350 ans du bourgeois gentilhomme
alors oui c'est ça 770 un siècle plus
c'est incroyable de 70 voilà minable ce
70 c'est très beau puisque là on va dire
par la dernière grande oeuvre de molière
mais presque en tout cas celle qui nous
a laissé le plus de travail avec balais
comédie ballet de molière et lully ses
770 c'est le bourgeois gentilhomme
alors on reprend une production qu'on a
déjà fait avec denis podalydès qu'un peu
de la maison à versailles et averses
allaient de la comédie française salle à
cette production qui l'a fait avec des
comédiens d'exception et qui va on va
dire qu'elles ont la reprend pour la
dernière fois puisque la production
annuelle à 10 ans on a déjà fait quatre
fois une série ça sera la cinquième et
là on a le spectacle qui plaît aux
grands et aux petits
je pense que c'est peut-être le
axe de molière qui est absolument
inusable et indestructible et à mourir
de rire ben hammam en étions permanente
d'une modernité absolue
et puis qui colle bien ici dans une mise
en scène dont les décors et la
scénographie sont d'eric ruf qui dirige
la grille midi française tous est d'une
grande beauté d'une grande habileté et
magistralement interprété par sa voix là
on a un succès absolu moi je sais que
j'ai à faire mais il faut voir ça en
fera t il y aurait si un ballet sur
marie antoinette de monaco d'un c'est ça
thierry malandain qui est aussi de la
région son père le maire de trappes a
reçu par mois une amende non alors il
dirige le ballet de biarritz aujourd'hui
et je lui ai passé commande ya quelques
années d'un balai sur maria antona terry
m'a dit non mais j'y arriverai jamais
c'est trop compliqué
la politique comment s'en sortir ouais
et puis les avancées dans leur sulfureux
à sa toujours compliqué et il est rentré
dans le truc et il en a sorti un opéra
littéralement depuis l'arrivée de marie
antoinette à versailles c'est à dire le
jour de l'inauguration de cars
puisqu'elle est arrivé le jour de son
mariage jusqu'à son départ en 1789 donc
on n'a pas les chats faut on n'a pas la
jeunesse à vienne mais il ya na rien
vous savez y découvre le personnel
alors c'est une fois de plus un
spectacle qui parle à la fois de
l'histoire et de ce personnage et qui en
parle dans l'opéra à l'époque déjà et
c'est assez alors c'est un très beau
spectacle jouer avec un orchestre dans
la fosse qui jouent des symphonies de
haydn et c'est magnifique et on reprend
à nouveau on en a fait une publication
en dvd et bien je vous propose de
regarder un extrait
[Musique]
mais
m
donc c'était le bal et marie-antoinette
de balanda alors il ya aussi j'ai vu une
chose assez étonnante c'est le platée de
rameau
par qui alors par parlera mot d'arabe au
régime et créé ce projet ce plat tu es
ici je rappelle c'est l'histoire d'une
grenouille que les dieux s'amuse à
transformer elle lui faire croire
qu'elle est une reine bientôt qu'elle va
être épousé par apollo qui descend du
ciel
et c'est une grande comédie du xviiie
siècle absolument extraordinaire et on a
demandé à charles et diana il dit nous
d'en faire la mise en scène
il avait déjà fait avec nous plusieurs
projets et évidemment ça les a botté
tout à fait puisqu'ils ont dit bon bah
on va faire ça mais alors au lieu que la
grenouille soit dans un marécage
ça sera plutôt une fille un peu légère
dans une banlieue pourrie cesse de
marécages moderne et tout ça bien sûr
avec la baguette d'hervé niquet qui est
pétillant dans ces musiques là et ça va
donner une plate et revu aujourd'hui
mais bien sûr la musique de rameau puis
la mise en scène va être comme toujours
avec shirley dino facile d'accès si
l'accès à la zone rouge alors y rajoute
des textes y rajoute des trucs comique
des numéros des chansons bon ça va se
créer bientôt ça sera je pense un très
bel événement très bel événement
alors j'ai relevé aussi une série de
vedettes qui vaut qu'ils vont venir il
ya ces cité apartheid il ya philippe
jaroussky jaroussky patricia petibon ça
c'est des récitals alors oui on donne
aussi en dehors de production scénique
des concerts des récitals parce que je
crois que c'est une manière de faire
venir des grands interprètes
d'aujourd'hui je pense à philippe
jaroussky cecilia bartoli qui sont des
habitués de la salle c'est vraiment des
salles pour leur voix c'est une salle
assez petit
elle donne vraiment on est prudent voire
gains c'est vraiment là on voit bien on
entend bien
le contact dans le récital c'est un
contact un peu physique sur est donc ici
votre proche de celle en bonheur on voit
le blanc des yeux du chanteur ça compte
surtout quand il les a aussi beau que
cecilia bartoli et puis à toute votre
politique vous reparler du valais
barrière toilettes de dvd de publication
de dvd alors oui on a décidé puisque on
fait les concerts pourquoi pas de les
enregistrer de temps en temps et de
faire ben déjà une bientôt 25 cd et dvd
enregistré tous lors de concerts au
château de versailles
et bien sûr ils sont pas seulement
enregistré pendant le concert on fait ce
qu'on appelle des patchs à dire mon
complète pour avoir vraiment le son
idéal et l'interprétation idéal les
jours avant les jours après et c'est une
mémoire est aussi ça touche tout un
public qui n'a pas pu venir au spectacle
ici et qui va en france ou à l'étranger
trouver ses oeuvres alors j'ai pas le
grand choc de la chapelle avec jean
baptiste robin qui en est un titulaire
ici dès noël baroque chanter à
versailles par des enfants et gaëtan
jarry et puis par exemple à des nations
de faust le grand opéra berlioz dans le
décor de 1837 qu'on avait remonté pour
l'occasion sur le plateau là il ya des
moments comme ça un peu exceptionnel et
on peut se les procurer ou et coloris
sont en vente partout vous pouvez
acheter des disques il a sur internet et
puis bien sûr sur notre site et dans
notre boutique rue des réservoirs à
versailles au pied de l'opéra on peut
faire verser chez soi il ya aussi
stravaganza d'emblée non alors il ya
aussi sera la contrada mort et qu'il
faut sortir qui est un projet café
raphaël pichon sur les prémices de
l'opéra en italie juste avant leur flot
de monteverdi qui est la première vraie
pièces d'opéra il ya toutes ces musiques
qui ont qui sont quasiment la moitié ou
le tiers d'un opéra et qui sont auteurs
moins connus et les a tous mis en scène
les uns avec les autres dans la galerie
des glaces pour une musique et un moment
absolument extraordinaire donc ça sont
des moments qu'il faut savoir grave et
c'est un petit peu comme si aujourd'hui
on pouvait retrouver des moments anciens
dont on a plus de traces et qui ont été
dont on sait qu'ils ont été fantastiques
là pour une fois on garde le son et
l'image voilà
pichon de l'opéra italien la galerie des
glaces alors on n'a pas donné de date
pour tous ces spectacles y en a beaucoup
d'autres
son haleine dans quelques-uns il ya une
centaine pour envoyer un site château de
versailles grâce à des spectacles on
trouve facilement et qui on les mettra
aussi sur le site de tv 68 merci
infiniment merci beaucoup plus lisse et
bonne saison
elle sera est excellente
[Musique]